Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to be speaking
with Chris Tarbell, former FBI special agent
and now founding partner at Nexo, was involved
in the eventual takedown of the Silk Road,
which I've spoken a little bit about before.
Chris, great to have you on today.
Really appreciate it.
Speaker 2: Oh, thanks for having me on, David.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 1: So, you know, to start just somewhere
as I read about the story of how Ross Ulbricht
and the Silk Road were ultimately taken down,
one of the things that is often described
as the story is told in many of the books
about it is that it's really like the prototypical
example of different law enforcement agencies
in the U.S. not working well together, which
is sort of like this narrative that often
exists about, well, the FBI wants credit.
Well, this also involved HCI and involved
all these different agencies.
And the Silk Road would have been taken down
much sooner were egos put aside.
That's a story that's often told.
Do you think that that's fair as far as the
way that it went?
Speaker 2: No, not exactly.
You know, the other agencies were doing good
investigations.
HCI had good investigations going as far as
going up the chain.
But unfortunately, this is a new way of dealing
drugs.
I mean, this was you know, they were the buyers
didn't know who the dealers were.
The dealers didn't know the admins were, you
know, And so it really was just, you know,
it didn't go the normal investigative route.
You know, when did this new cyber route?
Speaker 1: So for people who don't know what
the Silk Road was, can you give them sort
of a brief synopsis?
I mean, it was it was a dark Web site that
was originally, I believe, dealing mostly
in illegal drugs, but actually came to be
much more than that.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
It was an online dark market Web site operated
on the Tor network, the Onion Router.
It was a hidden network developed by the Navy
back in the late nineties.
And you can't trace ships traditionally through
it.
It's it works on a different protocol that
kind of hides where the traffic is coming
from and going to.
But it also worked through anonymity, through
cryptocurrency.
This was the early stages of Bitcoin, so you
literally could go on there and buy almost
anything.
It was a $1.2 billion empire by the time we
took it down.
Now, there were two things you couldn't buy
on Silk Road.
You couldn't buy guns because that was on
a different website and you also couldn't
buy fake IDs or sorry, fake college degrees.
You could buy fake IDs.
You couldn't get a fake college degree.
They didn't want you to be like a doctor and
and not really have the education.
Speaker 1: When this started to become an
investigation that involved multiple agencies.
What was really or let me put it a different
way.
What were their concerns about where it could
go?
Or was the concern really what was already
taking place with it?
Speaker 2: Really it was what was already
taking place, you know, in the FBI.
And I can't speak for any desire or Iris or
DEA in their investigations.
The FBI investigation really came out of we
had a lot of cases around that time.
It was 2011, 2012.
A lot of cases just ended.
It was tore.
We can't do anything about it.
So we had just done a big case involving Anonymous
and the arresting of Sabu, Hector Montecore
and one of the other guys on on the anonymous
case was a guy named Jeremy Hayman, and he
was arrested and we were using Tor.
So it was one of those interesting things
we didn't do anything with.
Tor just happened.
That's how he's hiding.
And it took us an extra six months to find
him.
But once that case was over, we started sitting
around and thinking about maybe we should
take a look at Tor and see if we can do.
There's so many cases being closed just because
it comes up as a Tor IP address.
Speaker 1: If I recall correctly, a big kind
of breaking point in starting to look at Ross
Ulbricht.
Was someone involved in the investigation
and it's been a little while since since I
read the book about the investigation, someone
put together an old handle that Ross used
on some message board, which then they figured
out, Oh, that's the I recognize that that's
also appearing elsewhere.
Remind us of that detail.
But maybe more importantly, how long did the
Silk Road investigation go before the name
Ross Ulbricht ever actually was mentioned?
Speaker 2: Well, So there's a there's a path
there.
There's a story there that, you know, it's
kind of difficult.
So there we the connecting the word, the name
you're looking for is frosty.
Yes.
So someone on a on a message board way back
at the start of Silk Road posted, Hey, I'm
starting this onion site and it's going to
use cryptocurrency if anybody has any programing
to help reach out to me at Frosty and I was
posted in the username Frosty in the forums,
right?
Is that reach out to me at Ross dot Ulbricht
at gmail.com.
Right.
Which again is a clue in our world.
Yes Not until we found the server and was
able to go through sort of the networks of
the server and find that there was a backup
server in Philadelphia.
And then there was a computer that was reaching
out to the backup server in the name of the
computer was frosty.
So now we have, you know, this this computer
being run by DPR, Dread Pirate Roberts, the
guy who operated Silk Road, you know, and
then his posting of From Frosty with the email
address, Ross Ulbricht at gmail.com.
Speaker 1: And that was originally the way
that the investigation turned to look specifically
at Ulbricht.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I mean, we had to develop
a few other things before we knew that he
was in the Pacific Coast time because there
was a Jabber server that he had set up.
That's a communication server for his admins
to talk on, and we knew that his timeframe
was around then, but that specifically, that
was where we connected Ross through that frosty
connection.
Speaker 1: If you look at critiques of the
way that Ulbricht was ultimately prosecuted,
it seems what most often comes up is something
along the lines of, you know, the drug part.
Increasingly, there is a view that drugs should
be decriminalized.
At minimum, many should actually be legalized
more commonly with cannabis than with cocaine.
But this is sort of like the way things have
kind of moved over the last decade, 15 years,
particularly libertarians like Ulbricht subscribe
to that ideology.
And there are many who say that were it only
the drugs alone, really what was happening
shouldn't actually have been against the law.
However it went over into.
You could hire hitmen on the Silk Road and
it went over into all this other stuff that
I think is more universally thought of as
like, you know, that that stuff definitely
shouldn't be legal when someone like you or
others in the FBI are investigating something
like this, how much or does it matter at all
what your personal feelings are about?
For example, which drugs, if any, should be
illegal or decriminalized or legalized, or
does it quite literally never enter into the
work as you are investigating something like
this?
Speaker 2: It really never enters into the
work.
I mean, so I was assigned to New York.
I was especially in New York.
And and I like to say in New York, you know,
it's so specialized.
There's, you know, let's I jokingly say there's
a bank robbery.
And the first question is, was the bank robber
left handed or right handed?
Because there's one squad handles left in
bank robbery, the other side handles right
handed.
Right.
You know, you're put on a squad.
And we were very we were criminal cyber intrusions.
So we were the hacking criminal hacking crew.
That was that was our squad.
And there's another squad that did national
security hacking.
So really, you know, I was just investigating
hacking and really Tore had come up We had
partnered up with start with Southern District
of New York, who had a case with the DEA at
the time and then brought in the IRS.
And so really I was looking at 18 U.S.C. 1030
violation of hacking rules.
And that was one of the things sold on Silk
Road was was hacking tools or hacks for hire.
And so that was sort of the nexus.
But really, when we opened up the Silk Road
case, we opened up 25 of the Onion sites and
it really was more looking into using Tor
as a way of hiding criminal activity.
Speaker 1: When you see the sentence that
Ulbricht ultimately got, which was, I believe,
two life sentences without the possibility
of parole.
Speaker 2: Does 40 years.
Speaker 1: Plus 40 years.
Okay.
Does that seem like the right sentence for
what he did?
Speaker 2: That is not my decision.
You know, I'm a part of the you know, thank
God the government has different branches.
You know, I'm part of the I was part of the
executive branch where no doubt the laws,
you know, the legislative branch does the
you know what laws there are.
And the judicial branch does come up with
the punishments.
So that that's where we are.
My scope of expertise.
Speaker 1: No.
But as a guy who now is out and just might
have an opinion.
Speaker 2: I really don't have an opinion
on it.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: And I'm not suggesting I don't
know that.
I mean, sometimes people say that because
they don't want to answer.
I actually am open to the idea that you really
just that's not the way you think about these
things.
You have a particular role in this whole thing.
Speaker 2: Yeah, certainly.
I mean, I'm not I wouldn't be upset if someone
I arrested, you know, was let go.
I mean, I. I arrested Hector months ago or
he spent months in jail, was facing hundred
25 years, but did a great job.
I'm not offended by all the work I put in.
And he got out and didn't got got.
He was only in prison for for nine months
for for what he did.
You know, that doesn't offend me in any sort
of way.
So, yeah, I really don't have an opinion on
it.
Speaker 1: What's the current state of Darkweb
marketplaces?
Because it's not really a topic in the news
right now, but it's sort of like by definition,
the idea is it's dark web, so you don't necessarily
know about it.
These aren't indexed websites.
You need a special browser to access it.
Do you know much about the current state of
these types of marketplaces?
Speaker 2: I do.
I'm still involved in them.
So, yeah, you know, you would ask me right
after Silk Road and right after Ross got sentenced
to all that, you know, two life sentences
in 40 years, I would have said it would have
gone down.
I would no one would do.
This is crazy.
But it actually exploded right after that.
There was a big state of, you know, people
setting up these sites and stealing people's
cryptocurrency.
But now it's become into, you know, there's
places, you know, and I don't want to tell
kids how to get there.
Right.
You know, But but there are many, many dark
money Web websites out there that you can
still still do many more than there were back
in the day.
Speaker 1: Are they ever based in the United
States or is that just like the height of
ignorance to approach it that way?
Speaker 2: I think some people probably still
do it in the United States.
You know, it's it's sort of a Whac-A-Mole.
Someone makes a mistake, a configuration issue
or something like that, and law enforcement
gets them.
But the latest takedowns haven't really used
infrastructure in the United States that I've
seen.
Speaker 1: You mentioned the connection to
crypto and that crypto was often the payment
method that was used.
One of the interesting and full disclosure,
I have no emotional attachment to this question.
I also have no opinion.
I was not early, but you know, 2016 I bought
some bitcoin and it did really well and I've
mostly sold all of it and I have no opinion
as to where it's going or how much it's used
for criminality.
One of the arguments that was made early about
Bitcoin was it's overwhelmingly used for criminal
activities.
But my understanding is that when the Silk
Road was shut down, the throughput of transactions
barely changed at all, which sort of would
be a counterpoint to the idea that Bitcoin
was primarily being used for criminal transactions.
Did you, in your investigative work, come
to have an opinion about that and how regularly
criminal motivations were at play for Bitcoin
transactions?
Speaker 2: So, you know, in my world as an
FBI agent, I only looked at criminal activity.
So yeah, I saw it attached to everything.
I mean, it really was the birth of ransomware.
You mean we've had encryption for, you know,
75 years, you know, digital encryption and
that sort of thing, all the way back to, you
know, the Nazis encryption, you know, the
Enigma machines, you know, So that's not new.
What really was the rise for ransomware was
the popularity of cryptocurrency.
So, you know, we're fighting we're still fighting
to that to this day on that sort of thing.
So, you know, I am a technologist.
I liked cryptocurrency.
I like I see the point of it.
I like that, you know, two people can meet
in a far off place and make a transaction
and it's locked in place within, you know,
60 minutes at most.
But I see a lot of criminal activity connected
to it.
Speaker 1: What are you seeing now in terms
of the trends of the cyber threats, scams,
phishing at the individual level?
If you're able to comment on it, you know,
about five years ago, I was getting a lot
of the, hey, you know, tax money and we're
sending the police to your house, to which
I would say send them.
Sounds interesting.
Obviously.
I know I don't you know, I'm not giving you
any money.
Social Security scams.
Give us access to your computer and we'll
like log into your bank, that sort of stuff.
I'm not being targeted by that anymore.
I'm getting a lot more sort of like telemarketing
stuff, like wanting to sell me warranties
on vehicles I don't even have and this sort
of thing.
What are the trends right now?
What's going on?
Speaker 2: So we're seeing a lot of phishing
scams for crypto theft.
So any sort of like accounts that are taken
over where it's sent out that you're.
Sort of a crypto network.
If you're part of an exchange, you know, you'll
start getting a lot of phishing emails.
And the vishing, the the phone calls give
me access.
And then because it's so easy, you don't have
to.
They give access to their computer and and,
you know, just take the wallets right out
right there.
You don't have to convince them to do anything
more.
I think the one of the biggest trends and
so I hosted a podcast with Hector Monzo.
You're Sabu, the guy who arrested Hacker in
the Fed, and he made a prediction.
And I agree with him that this year we're
going to see a lot more insider threats from
people inside networks who we give access
to are going to be stealing data.
You know, he kind of made that prediction
based on the large technology layoffs we've
we've seen lately.
But we're seeing more and more, you know,
networks have been predicted from the outside,
and very few people are doing things to protect
internal network stuff.
Speaker 1: What's the lowest hanging fruit
right now just for individuals in terms of
protecting themselves?
Speaker 2: What can they do better?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, you know, I know
people who, for example, they just don't pick
up their phone anymore.
And just by doing that, unless they they quite
literally know who's calling them, even if
they think it might be their bank, They just
do not pick up the phone as an example.
And that right there knocks 50% down or, you
know, that type of thing.
Speaker 2: Yeah, no, I would definitely do
that.
You know, the email stuff is still the phishing
stuff, but one of the easiest things you can
do is called segmentation.
There's no moisture, no more flat networks
at work.
You'll never see just one router and everyone
connects to the same router in any office.
But we're seeing that at home.
Still, a lot of people just have one router.
They give their passwords out to people that
come and visit or that sort of thing or when
they connect Internet of the things when your
thermostat is connected to your router.
A lot of thermostats and things like that
have hardcoded passwords or they don't change
the administrator passwords.
Well, that's a whole write into your network.
So segmentations, either through VLANs or
having physical different devices, have you
know, more than one router in your house and
secure it that way.
Speaker 1: Oh, that's interesting.
So for example you could you could set up
a separate wi fi network for the thermostats
alone and you on your phone never connect
to that network.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Anything you do banking on should not be on
the same as your Internet of things, especially
things that punch what I call punching holes
in the firewall.
So because you can change your thermostat
from outside your house, right.
Because you can look at cameras that you've
had connected to your Internet.
Those are holes in your firewall.
That means that, you know, it's an entry point
into the defense system.
So, you know, have a different network that
doesn't have that connected to it used for
your, you know, banking, logging into banking
accounts and that sort of thing.
Speaker 1: All right.
That's useful and actionable and it's not
unrealistic.
You know, sometimes the tips you read are
like, yes, I could do that, but I'm basically
segregating myself out of the way society
is operating, which is not practical.
It is it's like a diet that you can only sustain
for a week.
It's not super useful long term.
Yeah.
Speaker 2: Those are super cheap now.
So is it really a thing you can do and you
know, configuration?
There's a lot of YouTube videos out there
that can help.
You can figure, you know, different networks.
Speaker 1: We have been speaking with former
FBI special agent Chris Tarbell, now a founding
partner at Nacs.
So, Chris, really appreciate your time and
your insights today.
Speaker 2: Thanks so much for having me on.
I appreciate it was fun.